[Música]
é exatamente o que vocês estão vendo
meus amigos é isso mesmo o povo pediu o
povo já não aguentava mais ficar calado
o povo se cansou e eu cortei o cabelo ai
meu Deus como é bom voltar 2013 galera
de Maceió Tô voltando para aí viu Maceió
que agora dia 29 sábado lá no ginásio do
Sesi lá de Aracaju galera Itabaiana dia
30 eu tô aí tá no mesmo dia dos shows tá
é no site www.
vamos passar uns dias de férias amor né
Aí eu falei amor vamos passar um dia de
férias vamos para onde senão Jamaica
aqui pertinho pessoal diz só falei
beleza a gente foi para Jamaica a gente
pegou o avião tá não sei quem aí o eu
não sei falar inglês eu Definitivamente
não sei falar inglês eu falo as coisas
que não tem nada a ver eu de manhã 7:00
da manhã eu encontro com gripe no meio
da rua de Gude night eu não define
novamente Não sei avião né pá aí o
piloto Eu já falei enrolado o piloto da
vida real brasileiro Ele já fala
o comandante Ô 27 graus
de Aracaju e o dos Estados Unidos que é
inglês
entendeu
Nova York
Harry Potter Eu não entendi nada Ele
podia falar tenho certeza se vocês
passageiros desse tamanho diretamente
para o inferno eu ia falar pô tranquilo
vamos embora e nós no avião eu não sei
eu já vou repetir eu vou repetir porque
eu não sei falar inglês assim no avião
Primeiro ela vem perguntar que a gente
quer comer a mulher vai perguntar pra
mim ela olhou para mim e falou assim que
lanche eu escreve de outro jeito quer
dizer almoço e eu não sabia eu pensava
que era lanche e no avião dependendo da
Companhia Aérea ele só recebe em
dinheiro ou cartão de crédito e eu tava
sem dinheiro e com cartão de débito não
tinha não tenho crédito não uso crédito
aí A mulher chegou para mim e falou
lanche eu digo não Senhora não tenho
dinheiro não aí ela olhou para mim e
falou dinner eu falei eu não tenho
dinheiro minha senhora como é que eu vou
comprar lanche sem dinheiro não deu 10
minutos tava todo mundo com seus Lanches
comendo que é o almoço depois veio o
Dina que a janta e eu morrendo de fome e
aí vocês tem que aprender a falar inglês
a gente tem que aprender a falar inglês
não tem condição não pousou na jamais
posou aí OK você sabe que tem aquela
entrevista cara olha por visto olha para
você para ver se é você mesmo na foto e
tal aí eu sabia que férias porque é
vacations eu sabia que férias é vacation
porque eu vi no pica-pau pica-pau ficou
de férias aí eu vi o nome escrito eu
sabia que era isso né ficar na cabeça da
criança vocês pensam que a criança não
lembra da escola eu lembro assim mas não
sabia falar só que eu conheço um
professor que é o Mairo Mairo Vergara eu
já postei um vídeo no Instagram um dia
indicando o coisa dele porque é muito
interessante porque ele ensina a falar
umas frases muito legal então você
aprende falar coisa por coisa bem
interessante OK aí eu mandei o áudio
para ele é Mário como é que fala
vacation aí ele me ensinou sílaba
pulseira falei ver queijo mano tipo
Playstation aí o cara perguntou pra mim
olhou para mim e falou assim você quer
não sei o que não sei lá aí eu olhei
para o cara falei que é isso é
como se eu soubesse há anos vai lá se
tem anos que eu não tenho nem férias
veja lá falar inglês férias aí beleza aí
eu fui pegar o táxi Achei um cara o cara
olhou para mim e falou assim você quer
não sei o que lá eu falei é aí ele
falando não sei o quê não sei o quê eu
falei é só vamos ir aí esse cara que
tava comigo era
imenso meu irmão pense num homem grande
eu acho que fazia Freire na cabeça dele
aqui em cima é frio comecei a pensar que
os cabelos brancos que ele tinha aqui
não era cabelo branco que era neve aí
ele tava chegou e foi conversar com
outro cara do táxi ele começa com o cara
do táxi o cara o cara olhou pra ele e
falou você quer dizer que tá não sei o
que lá aí o cara do táxi que era
menorzinho falando não sei o quê não sei
o que lá não sei o que lá o quê não sei
o que lá aí o grandão olhou pra ele
falando não sei o quê não sei o que lá
rapaz você me respeita o baixinho olhou
pra ele falou não sei o quê não sei o
quê lá não sei o que lá é o [__]
rapaz ora [__] meu irmão pequenininho
tá que você olhou pra mim falando não
sei o que não sei o quê lá aí eu fiquei
assim parado eu falei rapaz eu tô com
ele aqui que é maior qualquer coisa ele
ele resolve aí as coisas aí beleza eu
não sei que fim levou os caras deram as
mãos fez assim e eu entrei dentro do
táxi
meu irmão
agora que vem a parte interessante eu
juro para você pela alma da minha mãe da
minha família A primeira coisa que o
taxista falou comigo quando eu entrei
dentro do táxi eu e a Luiza Hein gente
entrou dentro do táxi Quando Ele olhou
pra gente a primeira coisa que ele falou
não foi good morning good night good
night Ele olhou pra gente e falou assim
ó
ele perguntou se a gente fuma fuma aí a
gente falou não não Ele olhou para a
gente fez assim ó já veio cá já vem cá
falei primeira palavra que entrou com um
cara meu irmão no hotel é um povo tudo
tranquilo todo mundo tranquilo bicho
Parece brincadeira parece que eu tô
inventando parece assim ah não é porque
é piada de Jamaica é falar de maconha
não é cara todo mundo é assim todo mundo
todo mundo bicho eu cheguei na recepção
aí chequinho eu falei sequinha ela é
você quer não sei o que lá tá não sei o
que lá passa a porta aí a gente deu aí
deu passaporte e tal não sei o quê
fez tudo lá estão pegando nossas coisas
fomos levar para o cara da mala o cara
quer levar a mala para o nosso quarto aí
eu falei eh bags bags e o cara é não sei
o quê não sei o que lá não sei o que lá
tal pegou as malas levou para o quarto
marcamos um passeio para de tarde nós
morde e apressado 15 minutos atrasado
para pegar o ônibus chega lá em baixo
moço o coisa
carcar morrendo de apressado correndo e
o cara Ah tá não sei o que lá não sei o
que lá não sei o que lá olhar para mim e
fala não sei o que lá fico com quem você
acalma calma aí beleza chegou a hora do
almoço e a mulher veio com uma tal do
lanche não sei o que lanche eu falei
minha senhora pelo amor de Deus meio-dia
e meio não é de lanche eu lanche no
lanche não lanche arrumou o sol almoço
almoço por favor almoça ela no lanche
lanche que [__] é lanche aí eu fui no
YouTube no canal do Mairo Mairo Vergara
lá eu vou já eu digo o canal para vocês
aprendi um monte de coisa que ela tem
muita coisa não achei o tal do lanche aí
fui lá no WhatsApp falei Mário O que é
esse lanche que Ele oferece todo dia um
lanche meio-dia não é o de lanche aí ele
moço é almoço o lanche que eles falam O
lanche é outro é outra pronúncia tá ele
me ensinou lá que eu me esqueci aqui
gente é almoço meu amigo eu falei meu
Deus do céu tô negando os almoço tudinho
desde os Estados Unidos para cá morrendo
de fome mais e o Dener ele falou é
jantar meu amigo eu falei Mário tá com
três dias que eu não janto nem almoço
mano daí para frente meu amigo vai
chegar lancha de lanche dois tio lanche
tchu para cá eu quero é muito Dinha
traga o Dina este negócio de gorjeta
esse teu negócio é o seguinte a comida
deu 50 dólares se você tiver $100 e você
der o $100 você dá o 100 dólares fala
assim tem que já vai saindo eu digo não
senhor Ei troco troco por favor
trocou de novo atrás do Mario Mario pelo
amor de Deus mas está indo embora com
meu dinheiro Mário sem dono Ele
respondeu o troco é Change Change eu
falei tipo um poder assim
aí eu fui lá no balcão aí eu fui embora
com meu dinheiro Cadê meu Change cadê a
mulher não sei o quê não sei o que lá
tal e pai não sei o quê Fazendo de
desentendida não sei o quê não sei que
lá e tal aí veio o cara o gerente olhou
para ela dizendo não sei o quê não sei o
que lá não sei o quê aí ela olhou ela
olhou para ele e falou então não sei o
quê não sei quem mais lá e tal não sei o
quê Tá Change eu ouvi Change eu falei
Change é Change mesmo me dê meu Change
ela zangou disse não sei o quê lá tá não
sei que não sei que lá
eu falei me dê meu Change você precisa
de um change de 50 dólares nessa
confusão a gente foi num bar eu e a
Luiza a gente foi num lugar lá onde a
galera mergulhava nossa água azulzinha
Que Só Meu Deus do Céu e lá eu encontrei
bicho eu juro por Deus na Jamaica eu
encontrei um brasileiro lá tipo 0
brasileiro 0 não vejo em lugar nenhum
Brasileiro aí patrão eu encontrei um
cara em Recife chama Pablo ele falou meu
irmão velho não acredito que não
chegasse lá tu né irmão velho é muito
doido aqui velho eu sou de Recife tô na
casa dos nativo aí eu fiquei feliz que
eu encontrei um brasileiro né pô aí
podia conversar podia pedir ele para
comprar as coisas pra mim e tal foi
interessante uma coisa
importantíssima sobre a Jamaica que você
tem que entender toda música do mundo
tem uma versão em reggae na jamais
sempre que a gente andava com guia
turístico sempre que a gente andava num
carro que a gente dava no ônibus que a
gente andava a pé que a gente qualquer
coisa tinha uma música Meu amigo
despacito
entre uma ideia
[Música]
despacito
tem o Wesley Safadão aí para nós
tirar na balada só dando o virote e eu
tô de bobeira sem ninguém na geladeira
Um Evangélico bota uma música evangélica
aí para mim acabou de mel tem sabor de
mel a minha vitória hoje tem sabor de
mel aí nós vamos fazer um passeio lá e
tal
é fundo esse Lago Aí eu falava fundo
fundo assim assim é esse gay foi uma má
com ele era bem devagarzinho ele falou
ah não sei que lá tal
Sei lá Falei deve ser fundo é melhor
ficar só pelas beiradazinha mesmo só que
não apareceu Pablo do nada e meu irmão
velho tu é doido eu tô na casa dos
Nativa que eu sou de Recife tá ligado
que eu sou de Recife né Muito doido aqui
velho estou muito doido mergulho eu
tinha que concordar com tudo que o cara
falava porque eu não entendi o cara é tá
não sei o quê lá e tal não sei queimar
lá hambúrguer e aí hambúrguer show hein
gosto hambúrguer é mato ele tá não sei o
que lá por ali e tal sei lá e tal
ketchup fala Eita aí sim é bom aí hein
nativo aqui tá ligado muito doido menino
para [__] para todo lado tem muito
menino e tal os cara tem uma plantação
de maconha muito doido meu irmão sou de
Recife tá ligado consegui Recife e vocês
tem que aprender inglês cara Jamaica é
um país muito lindo mas eu sem saber
falar inglês eu não sabia fazer nada
cara porque nos outros lugares do mundo
Eles não estão nem aí pro português eles
sabem inglês e espanhol só e não estão
nem aí pro português meu irmão se você
chega no lugar que é uma bola você fala
assim oh bola eu quero uma bola o cara
Oh quer dizer que em inglês né que isso
eu sei para bola você faz assim oh bola
oh bola chutar bola
bolacha bola futebol futebol Pelé Pelé
Maradona Neymar bola mano passa um
japonês à tarde você já poderia ter
falado ai ai
ele entende o cara bola em inglês é bom
bom que é quase bola meu irmão quase não
não quer saber agora a gente sabe chegar
um gringo numa loja faz isso aqui falar
b a gente fala bola né bola quer uma
bola cleito traz uma bola aqui para o
branquela aqui uma bola 15 minutos tá o
gringo mais 12 brasileiros jogando bola
no meio do asfalto o cara tem que
aprender a falar inglês cara eu tava
aperriado no mato Pescador e o Moço eu
queria tal do nada parecia Pago meu
irmão velho tu é doido eu tô aqui na
casa dos nativos Tu é doido eu sou de
Recife tá ligado né A gente foi pro
hotel triste não tava entendendo as
coisas não sabia falar passamos quatro
dias conhecendo cachoeira na Jamaica o
lugar maravilhoso o melhor lugar do
mundo água e água pra [__] Pablo que
aparecia do nada estava eu e a Luiza
ponto para dormir na cama apareceu Pablo
meu irmão velho tu é doido é que eu tô
velho isso de Recife tá ligado que eu
sou de Recife tem uma casa nativo e o
Mário que é o professor ele ensina pra
[__] tá ligado Tipo tudo que ele
ensinou Tá ligado Velho isso é de Recife
tudo que ele ensinou pra mim nessa
viagem eu aprendi e ficou pra mim até
hoje porque o modo de ensinar dele é
diferenciado então se você também quiser
conhecer o canal do Mario e aprender
inglês bem mesmo assim é o primeiro link
da descrição do vídeo você pode clicar
que é o canal do Mario Vergara atende o
inglês varada mesmo ou pode clicar aqui
na tela também se você quiser vai direto
para o canal do Maia lá você pode se
inscrever para aprender o inglês filé
mesmo gente boa meu irmão velho meu
irmão tô na casa do nativo se você tiver
gostado desse vídeo clique em gostei
aqui no YouTube tá Não esquece aqui ó
você que tá no Twitter Vamos bater esse
recorde de RT vamos dar uns 10.000 RT
nesse vídeo aqui clique em RT nele vamos
dar RT você que tá na fotinha de
divulgação lá no Instagram curte a foto
volta lá no Instagram curte a foto lá
que você viu assim vídeo novo Facebook é
muito importante que você curta eu tenho
que ficar ensinando isso toda hora
pessoal eu posto Facebook galera ver aí
vem pra cá pro YouTube mas não curte a
publicação de like que ela viu Curte lá
e é isso aí Valeu então